le 20 juin 1907 à 4 heures de l'après
midi
des hommes des femmes des enfants toute
une foule s'avance vers l'hôtel de ville
de narbonne au premier rang de cette
foule il y a deux hommes qui tiennent à
blesser à blessés couverts de sang et
ses hommes s'avancent avec la foule vers
l'hôtel de ville devant l'hôtel de ville
il y à des soldats des soldats du 139e
régiment d'infanterie ces soldes en
baïonnette au canon ces soldats sont
chargés de garder l'hôtel de ville et la
foule avance toujours vers l'hôtel de
ville les gens qui suivent ceux qui sont
devant pour montrer qu'ils sont
pacifiques agitent des chapeaux des
mouchoirs et la foule avance toujours
les soldats attendent
et puis quelques ailes aux premiers
rangs de la foule l'un de ceux qui
tiennent le blessés cris nous vous
emmenons un blessé les soldats qui y
compris quatre ou cinq d'entre eux au
contraire s'avance et voilà que
maintenant ce sont les soldats qui
s'avance vers la foule qui court qui
pointent leurs baïonnettes qui frappent
à coups de baïonnette dans la foule un
homme reçoit un coup de baïonnette dans
le biceps et puis tout à coup ce sont
les fusils qui partent la foule qui
s'enfuit épouvanté qui hurle la pétarade
le tir sans contrôle une jeune fille 20
ans dont le crâne éclater un homme tombe
tu es un homme encore tué un homme
encore tué il y aura cinq mains une
tuerie une tuerie qui a atteint une
foule qui ne voulaient simplement que
dire sa misère
que dire qu'elle était victime d'une
injustice totale
les gens lui midi font du vin ils
vendent leur vin pour vivre depuis le
19e siècle c'est la grande récolte du
midi hier en cette année 1907 une
tragédie depuis quelques années s'est
abattue sur le midi on ne vend plus le
vin et comme on ne vend plus le vin on
meurt de faim la république 2009 de 1848
dès le jour de son avènement avait
proclamé le droit au travail cette foule
qui marchait sur l'hôtel de ville ne
voulait que demander son droit au
travail
ces gens là étaient désespérés ces gens
là étaient désespérés parce qu'on leur
permettait plus de travailler parce
qu'on ne leur permettaient plus de
vendre leur vin et l'histoire montre que
quand les hommes sont poussés au
désespoir
la tragédie est tout près mais qui a mis
le feu aux poudres
quand at on mis le feu aux poudres
d'abord sur le midi il y a eu un autre
fléau une autre calamité il y a eu au
19e siècle le phylloxéra appuis seront
un puits seront qui s'attaque notamment
à la vigne et dans les dernières années
du second empire le puceron le
phylloxéra a ravagé la ville française
la moitié de la vigne a péri les deux
tiers de la production ont été anéantis
et la france qui s'alimentait en vain
sur sa propre production
la france est obligée d'importer des
vins étrangers puis on a forcé la
production algérienne pour pallier les
vides du au phylloxéra
il a fallu des années on a planté
d'autres plats on est venu à bout du
phylloxéra au début du siècle
lavigne avait retrouvé sa place
la vigne française et même en 1905 on
verra une production plus importante
qu'avant le fil auxerre oui mais voilà
ces contre-temps ans dans
l'anéantissement de la ville française
et bien on l'a pris des habitudes on l'a
importée et donc il y à des filières il
y à des négociants il ya des marchands
tout ça existe et ces gens là n'ont pas
l'intention de se retirer d'abandonner
leur négoce
ils tiennent à continuer à importer et
puis on a augmenté la production du vin
d'algérie il faut bien les coulées se
vendent à lire première difficulté pour
la vigne française reconstitué mais il
ya pire on pourrait venir à bout de ces
difficultés elles sont disons le logique
normal mais pas de celle dont je vais
vous parler un grand savant qui
s'appelait chaptal un grand chimiste
avait montré le premier conçu crans le
20 ans l'obtient un vin d'un taux
d'alcool supérieur à ce qu'il serait
sans le sucre âge comme disait chaptal
on peut transformer les vins acerbes
en bon vin et la loi de 1903 avait
totalement admis que l'on sucre le vin
et alors avait commencé d'extraordinaire
abus des négociants sans vergogne avait
acheté des quantités de vin les avait
mouillé les avait su créé pour renforcer
le taux d'alcool les avait mis sur le
marché on était arrivé en certains
endroits en achetant par exemple 100
mille hectolitres en faire deux cent
mille hectolitres pourquoi pas
naturellement ce vin était vendu très
bon marché alors les vignerons qui eux
continuent à produire à l'ancienne un
excellent vin naturel
comment pouvait-il rivaliser avec ce vin
falsifiés
et ça n'était pas encore le pire
d'autres négociants fabriqués au jeudi
bien fabriqué il y avait bien bien des
méthodes par exemple ont acheté quelques
milliers de tonnes de raisins secs en
grèce ou en turquie
arrivé en france son lait mélangé à de
l'eau du sucre à du colorant pour faire
mieux
de l'acide aussi pour un petit peu
donner du corps à tout ça et c'était du
vin on vendait sa dans le commerce va on
mettait même quelquefois 20 supérieur
ont trouvé des noms des noms charmants
tue pas cher bien sûr c'était toujours
beaucoup moins cher que le vin naturel
produit par les paysans et je voudrais
vous lire je voudrais vous lire un
document une lettre extraordinaire et
c'est monsieur félix napo dans une étude
tout à fait remarquable sur la révolte
des vignerons qui l'a produit ce
document écoutez cela c'est un mode
d'emploi pour faire du vin vous allez
voir qu'elle va dans un fût défoncé m un
kilo d'acide tartrique un kilo d'acide
citrique un kilo d'acide sulfurique
pourquoi pas jeter dessus un litre ou
dodo froide pour éviter l'explosion
bah oui tant à faire puis m environ 60
litres d'eau bouillante agitée avec un
bâton et jeter dedans 100 kg de sucre
tenir le tout en mouvement en l'agitant
pendant une demi-heure le sirop ainsi
obtenu est prêt à envoyer
vous savez qu'il faut environ 100 kilos
de sucre pour 6 hectos de 20 à 10 degrés
le mélange ci dessus est bon pour 6
hectos et on leur nouvelle autant de
fois qu'il est nécessaire voilà vous
avez entendu un kilo et d'acide
tartrique acquis lots d'acide tartrique
citrique un kilo d'acide sulfurique
et les bons français buvait cela c'était
du vin on disait ça ne fait pas de mal
mais alors c'était vendu pour presque
rien qu'est ce que ça coûtait et une
fois de plus les vignerons ne pouvait
pas réel rivaliser avec ce vin
artificiel totalement artificielle alors
peu à peu les cuves des vignerons du
midi c'était rempli plus personne
n'achetait leur vin et peu à peu la
misère s'est abattue sur le midi une
misère affreuse totale quand la vendange
venez on trouvait les cuves pleines
alors on les ouvre et le vin s'écouler
dans la rue mais le nouveau vent le vent
n'est pas davantage les gens maintenant
le pensait plus à faire des bénéfices
il pensait à survivre une préoccupation
unique manger que les enfants mangent
que les femmes mangent que tout le monde
mange mais comment dans une entreprise
qui verse et en 1925 mille francs de
salaire
quatre ans plus tard on envers c'est
plus que le quart le salaire moyen de
l'ouvrier agricole était tombé à 2
francs
savez vous ce que représentait de francs
au début du siècle
une douzaine 2 et prenez un ouvrier qui
a une femme deux ou trois enfants avec
le prix d'une douzaine de il doit se
loger nourrir sa famille les vêtir vous
imaginez ça
lors on mange ce qu'on cultive on mange
des courges on mange des tomates on
mange des figues
adieu la viande bien entendu il ya une
ressource quand les enfants ou trop
envie de viande mais on n'attrape des
chats
malheur aux chats errants en ce temps là
dans le midi et puis pas de chaussures
une maîtresse d'école s'étonne pourquoi
il ya deux frères pourquoi ne voit
jamais les 2 en même temps et les
parents répondent ya qu une paire de
chaussures alors ils viennent
alternativement et puis il ya les impôts
ne sont pas des impôts sur le revenu ce
sont des impôts fonciers dont le taux a
été fixé forfaitairement d'autres temps
alors par exemple sur une vigne en paye
255 d'impôts par an mais que fait le
paysan qui a gagné en tout et pour tout
sur sa récolte 200 francs qui a dû vivre
avec ses 200 francs et quand on lui
réclame 250 francs oui la misère la plus
totale nous n'avons plus idée
aujourd'hui il ya de grands malheurs
aujourd'hui encore mais des misères
comme celle là c'est impossible
songez que des familles se nourrissent
de gland elle ramasse des glands et les
manges et ceux qui désespèrent le midi
c'est que ce grand malheur on a
l'impression là-bas que on ne le connaît
pas ailleurs en france
le reste de la france n'a pas l'air de
s'intéresser aux malheurs du midi paris
le gouvernement n'ont pas l'air de
s'intéresser aux malheurs du midi et
cette loi
cette loi de 1903 qui a autorisé la
fraude car elle a autorisé la fraude
qu'est ce qui va se passer ce qu'on va
éternellement mourir de faim est ce que
éternellement
on va attendre non il fallait que
quelqu'un donne le signal est ce
quelqu'un n'a pas été un grand
politicien du midi un homme célèbre dans
le midi un orateur non cet homme est un
homme seul obscures
rendons-nous dans un petit village à 20
km de narbonne
ar je lis argelier c'est un vieux
village avec un donjon du 14e siècle et
on cite le nom d'argeliers dans des
documents qui remonte au 11e siècle dont
c'est un très vieux village alors quand
on entre dans argelier bien on trouve
naturellement une place
et comme dans sur toutes les places du
midi et des platanes et puis comme sur
toutes les places du midi derrière les
platanes en trouve un café ce qu'a fait
c'est celui justement qui est tenu par
marcelin albert notre homme l'homme dont
je parlais à l'instant il est grand il
est chaud village une grande barbe très
noir malgré ses 56 ans tellement noir
que ses amis disent qu'il tient dans une
armoire un très bon flacon de teinture
ce cafetier n'est pas sans instruction
il a été à l'école jusqu'à 16 ans et
puis après il a dû aller aider sa mère
qui était veuve à la vigne à 10,9 en
1870 s'il s'est engagé dans l'armée
contre les prussiens pour faire la
guerre et puis après unis devenu caf du
personnage il aime le théâtre un moment
il a rêvé d'être acteur et puis le rêve
s'est enfoui
simplement il a fait du théâtre
d'amateurs il a joué dans la petite
salle qu d'argeliers bwin même des
villages de 12 cents habitants en ce
moment là un théâtre il a joué marceau
ou les enfants de la république puis la
jouait ruy blas et puis même en 1902
trois habitants d'argeliers dont le
pharmacien louis blanc ont écrit pour
lui une revue argelier dix minutes
d'arrêt il a joué dans cette revue sa eu
tellement de succès qu'on a joué trois
fois une vie sans histoire
oui mais voilà quand on n'est pas bête
et c'est le cas de marcelin albert et
quand on les cafetiers quand on tient un
café on voit beaucoup de monde on les
écoute le monde on entend beaucoup de
choses
et quand on n'est pas bête on réfléchit
or de quoi par les gens de la crise les
gens parlent de la misère les gens
parlent de leur désespoir il peu à peu
marcelin albert se dit que si personne
ne fait rien il faut au moins que
quelqu'un prenne une initiative et au
mois d'août 1903 quelques mois après la
loi il réunit au petit théâtre
d'argeliers des vignerons et leurs
parents
est ce le fait d'avoir fait du théâtre
martz cela albert à une éloquence
naturel il parle chaleureusement et à
l'accent qui roule dans sa voix il est
persuasif on écoute quand ils parlent et
ils l'attaquent deux choses la première
le privilège des bouilleurs de cru qui a
été supprimée si on la supprime et c'est
pour lutter contre l'alcoolisme
évidemment on l'a bien fait mais
marcelin albert dit que si on pouvait
continuer à faire de l'alcool eh bien on
pourrait distiller une partie de la
production et au moins on pourrait
écouler le produit de cette distillation
mais surtout ce qu'il a taxé la fraude
ceux qui l'attaquent selven falsifiés ce
qu'il a taxé le vin artificielle et
ovates ce jour-là une motion à
l'unanimité
protestant contre le vin artificielle et
demandant que le gouvernement
intervienne et on commence dans le
village de parler de marcelin albert
vous l'avez entendu marcelin albert ah
oui ils causent bien marc ce label et au
mois de septembre
marcelin albert fait venir au village le
député albert sarraut qui est un jeune
député qui freine très grande carrière
sous la troisième république plus tard
alors ça fait du bruit quand même un
député au village au théâtre essais
marcelin albert qui le présent
et qui parle de nouveau toujours
l'éloquence simple direct persuasive
et comme le député là il ya un
journaliste c'est un journaliste de la
dépêche de toulouse grand journal et le
lendemain on parle dans la dépêche de
toulouse de marcelin albert voilà que ce
nom tout à coup sort de l'obscurité
cela encourage marcelin albert qui au
mois de septembre aura l'audace d'aller
à narbonne à 20 km de là porter la
contradiction au député a eu 10 et dans
la salle il y a le maire de narbonne le
docteur ferroul
le bon docteur ferroul député socialiste
maire socialiste qui s'étonne de voir
cet obscur ce cafetier d'argeliers venir
porter la contradiction un député et
ferroul dit à ses amis une fou au une
foule une foule pas si fou peut-être
marcelin albert certains l'appellent
marceau à cause du rôle qu'il a joué
dans le mélodrame mars où les enfants la
république d'autres l'appellent loup
cigale lo cigal ça veut dire la tête
folle est ce que ça donne raison à
ferroul c'est vrai qu'ils déplacent du
vent c'est vrai qui ne tient pas en
place c'est vrai qu'il fait beaucoup de
bruit parce la halle b mais pas si fou
je vous assure
et il parle il va maintenant dans
d'autres villages il parle
les mois passent il attend qu'on la jce
il n'a pas encore la sensation que lui
marcelin-albert pourrait être le moteur
du mouvement mais enfin il attend que
d'autres se présente et en 1905
il réunit des vignerons de la région et
leur fait signer une pétition demandant
qu'on entreprenne à l'échelon
gouvernemental une lutte contre le vin
artificielle et en faveur du vin naturel
cela sauverait le midi 1905 c'est
le temps où les députés du midi
doumergue aldis à rouen déposé un projet
de loi contre la fraude contre le vin
salle si fier et le projet de loi n'est
pas passé la majorité du parlement la
rejeter et le midi tout entier ressens
cela comme une gifle et marcelin albert
plus que d'eau 1906 le président de la
république fallières succède à loubet
1907 le président du conseil
clemenceau succède à sa rien et en 1907
justement marcelin-albert à l'audace
d'envoyer un télégramme à clemenceau
comme s'il était quelque chose
c'est un appel un appel tragique
dramatique dans le style des gens du
midi et marcelin albert cris
le midi meurent de faim occupez vous du
midi pitié pour le midi et si l'on l'a
pas pitié pour le midi le midi se lèvera
et le sang coulera empêcher le sang de
couler signé marcelin albert on ignore
tout des réactions de clemenceau vais
tout de même à narbonne quelques temps
plus tôt le docteur ferroul le maire a
réuni d'autres mères quand même en se
disant est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas
faire quelque chose marcelin albert a eu
vent de la réunion il y est allé il a
voulu entrer il n'était pas mère alors
on l'a éconduit il est fou à 1pt férule
complètement fou alors il est parti
marcelin albert et puis tout à coup il y
avait une échelle qui traînait il a
dressé contre un platane il est monté
dans le platane est là dans le platane
savez un homme dans un platane ça se
remarque alors une petite foule s'est
réunie tout au tout il a parlé à cette
foule et il a dit pour défendre la vigne
c'est cent mille hommes que j'amènerai
afférents alors la foule harry lo cigal
la tête folle est tout de même ce
mouvement qui fait de plus en plus de
bruit cette presse qui s'agitent cette
presse du midi ces députés du midi qui
qui bouge
clemenceau fait quelque chose y sent
qu'il faut faire quelque chose
il nomme une commission denquête en
chassait le grand secret des républiques
quand ça ne va pas en nommer une
commission d enquête et on annonce
l'arrivée de la commission denquête dans
le midi et les journaux annoncent
qu'elle sera à narbonne le dimanche 11
mars
et c'est pour marcelin albert a trait de
lumière
il faut qu'il aille lui avec les autres
vignerons de la région
parlez à la commission denquête parlé au
président parlait aux députés il faut
que ce soit des gens qui souffrent qui
parle avec lui
et le 5 et le 6 mars y il bat le rappel
dans le village d'argeliers fait signer
une motion par quelques vignerons leur
donne rendez-vous pour le dimanche à 4
heures du matin il faut qu'on parte tous
ensemble et à 4 heures du matin le
dimanche il est devant son café
c'est encore la nuit un homme surgi de
la nuit le rejoins un second un
troisième set où plus rien ils regardent
dans la nuit personne ne vient comment
enfin commencer pas vrai ils viennent
qu'à 3 peut pas supporter ça alors il
court dans les rue marcellin-albert avec
sa barbe noire il faut avec sa veste à
trois boutons sa chemise blanche son
petit noeud papillon blanc qu'il ne
quitte jamais ils frappent aux portes
des amis alors et puis voilà qui la
visent
antoine marty le domestique de l'un de
ses amis
richard catala et lui dit dans marty et
on clairon bas il était la maison
monsieur albert bomba marty va va
chercher ton clairement tu viendras avec
nous à narbonne oui je veux bien et
marty va chercher son clairon et
marcelin albert lui dit tu vas sol et du
clairon dans toutes les rues partout
pendant un quart d'heure comme il a du
coffre marquis ça s'entend le clairon
alors toutes les fenêtres s'ouvrent ya
plus personne argelier qui dort et il ya
des gens qui se disent au fond
et s'il avait raison loup cigale de
vouloir qu'on aille à narbonne et si
c'était notre dernière chance et un peu
plus tard ils sont une cinquantaine sac
au dos qui sont là devant le café de
marcelin albert il ya le clairon marty
épi deux hommes qui sont venus avec des
temps bojana note il ya un drapeau et
c'est derrière ce drapeau derrière se
plairont et ses tambours que l'on pas
vers narbonne 20 km on savait marché à
cette époque et marcelin albert mène la
troupe et quand on traverse un village
et bien les tambours bapt le clairon
sonne et ya toujours quelques vignerons
qu'ils rallient le groupe d'argeliers
même sur la route on trouve l'ancien
curé d'argeliers et on lui dit vous
voulez avec nouvelle culture et ben oui
d'accord
et quand ils arrivent à narbonne ils
sont 87 cl son parti si tôt c'est qu'il
y avait une raison c'est que marcellin
albert voulais être là à l'heure où le
train entrait en gare
le train qui devait conduire la
commission l'enquète de paris ils sont
maintenant là la gare sur le quai et sur
lequel il ya le sous préfet monsieur
ricard a qu'une petite barbiche dont
beaucoup de barbe à cette époque là
monsieur car affolé qui s'approche de
marcio nalbert mais vous n'allez pas
faire du scandale
meuh non monsieur le sous-préfet nous
sommes pas des sauvages nous voulons
simplement faire entendre la voix des
vignerons du midi
le train s'arrête il ya sur le quai
encore monsieur ferroul qui est là le
maire de narbonne qui vit à ce sont ces
imbéciles d'argeliers se fout de
marcelin albert et les gens de la
commission descendre voix avec
étonnement ce groupe de 87
les vêtements couverts de poussière les
tambours le clairon le drapeau et
marcelin albert s'avance exprès demande
à être entendu le président d'ebay c'est
tout à fait d'accord tout à l'heure à la
sous préfecture
11 heures voilà le groupe d'argeliers
qui repart dans les rues ils marchent
d'un pas martial derrière les tambours
le clairon les gens les regardent passer
ils sont contents qu'on les regarde
c'est qu'on fait attention à eux et à 11
heures comme prévu marcelin-albert
entrent dans la salle où siège la
commission et il parle on n'a pas besoin
de chercher la misère il la connaît bien
et les exemples qu'il donne ce sont des
exemples qu'il a eu à côté de lui qu'il
a toujours à côté de lui ces pauvres
gens qui l'entourent et quand on connaît
bien un sujet et qu'on a du coeur
on n'a pas besoin de talent mais en plus
il a du talent marcelin albert et cette
commission l'écoutons dirait qu'elle
découvre le problème du midi et quand il
s'est tu le président dit monsieur
albert croyez que nous ferons tout pour
essayer de résoudre cette crise
dramatique
et ils repartent ils chantent la
vigneronne une sorte de marseillaise des
vignerons convient d'écrire et ils ont
le bonheur de voir que dans les rues de
narbonne et bien des gens reprennent le
refrain on dirait que ça y est
maintenant narbonne adhère au mouvement
lancé par marcelin albert et c'est vrai
que c'est ce dimanche 11 mars 1907 que
commence dans le midi la grande révolte
des vignerons entrée argelier
marcelin-albert constituent le comité de
défense vinicole il en était lui
naturellement le président n'y a pas
beaucoup de membres sont une dizaine
mais ça suffit à marcelin albert il les
réunit dans la salle attenante à son
café et l'ordi maintenant chaque
dimanche nous irons de village en
village de citer en cité nous
appellerons les gens du pays à s'unir à
s'unir pour se révolter et c'est vrai le
dimanche suivant le 24 mars
marcelin albert et son comité sont à
sallèles d'aude et c'est prometteur car
ils réunissent 300 vignerons dimanche 31
mars ils sont à bize six ans vigneron 7
avril
ils sont à aureilhan ouveillan et là ils
sont mille le 14 avril à coursan et là
ils sont huit mille qui sont venus
écouter marcelin-albert le 21 avril ils
sont à capestang et là ils sont 12
ligues et à ses 12000 on distribue un
journal le tocsin qui est le journal de
marcelin albert ce journal qui l'a voulu
et qui contient un éditorial qui est le
manifeste des gueux éditorial écrit par
le pharmacien louis blanc qui est
d'ailleurs le principal rédacteur
du tocsin le 28 avril ils sont à
lézignan 20000 le 5 mai ils sont à
narbonne à narbonne c'est fini les
petites foules
ce sont les grandes foules qui commence
à narbonne la foule arrive par toutes
les rues sur toutes les places combien
sont ils des dizaines de milliers qui
défilent dans les rues et qui se
réunissent devant l'estrade où siègent
marcelin albert et à côté de lui le
docteur ferroul et oui celui qui le
disaient fou est le docteur ferroul et
là les docteur ferroul prend la parole
et déclare je suis désormais le fidèle
lieutenant de marcelin albert à il passe
d'un extrême à l'autre
le docteur ferroul et marcelin albert
parle il parle aussi bien à des dizaines
de milliers de gens qu 300 du premier
village il ya si peu de temps ils
parlent marcelin albert et il dit il y a
deux ans j'ai promis d'amener à ferroul
cent mille hommes
eh bien ils sont là les cent mille
hommes alors vous imaginez la pl mation
le crime ans qui monte vers le ciel et
ferroul jure que désormais il
n'abandonnera pas le combat que toutes
les municipalités du midi d'abandon
l'ont pas le combat et c'est vrai que ça
continue c'est vrai que le 12 mai ils
sont à béziers à béziers où 150 mille
personnes sont venues acclamer marcelin
albert on a rarement vu on n'a peut-être
jamais vu dans l'histoire un mouvement
qui fait tâche d'huile au civil aussi
vite aussi fort et sur l'estrade
marcelin-albert parle toujours est
acclamé fait appel au courage des
vignerons
exige qu'on s'unisse pour combattre et
ferroul par l'oci et lance un ultimatum
à clemenceau si le 10 juin le
gouvernement n'a pas pris des mesures
pour faire cesser la crise viticole on
fera dans le midi la grève des impôts et
si le 13 juin
on n'a rien fait et bien les mairies
seront fermés et on se donne rendez-vous
pour huit jours plus tard à perpignan et
à perpignan une 580000 25 mai à
carcassonne
250000 le 2 juin à nîmes
trois cent mille trois cent mille et de
nouveaux marcelin albert qui harangue
les foules toujours le maintain grève
guerre haut-var artificielle grève de
l'administration grève de la mairie des
mairies combat vive le vin naturel et
ferroul qui déclare moi ferroul mois le
docteur ferroul
j'en donne ma parole le 10 juin
j'abandonnerai mammeri jolie serait le
drapeau noir sur ma mairie et toute la
foule trion d'izieu ain 10 juin 10 juin
mais avant le 10 juin il y à montpellier
et montpellier cela commence le 8 juin
le samedi 8 juin au soir sur toutes les
routes qui vont vers montpellier
la foule s'avance d'abord d'être un des
tracts qui partent de partout la
compagnie des chemins de fer du midi a
accordé 50 % de réduction et ses trains
arrivent toutes les 5 minutes en gare de
montpellier
des grappes humaines en descente
et puis sur les routes il ya tout de
charrette remplie de familles entières
des vieux omnibus bourré et puis des
armées entières de cyclistes et puis des
piétons qui avance en rangs serrés
derrière des pancartes des familles des
villages et puis quelques voitures
automobiles qui s'avance aussi des
voitures des propriétaires que tout va
remonte vers montpellier
et dès le samedi soir la ville est
pleine il ya deux cent mille personnes
le samedi soir cent mille personnes et
aucun désordre parce que l'un des hommes
d'argeliers l'un du comité d'argeliers
s'appelle elie berna c'est un ouvrier
boulanger bien cet élu bernard hilal
génie de l'organisation tous les
meetings qui ont eu lieu tous les
dimanches dans toutes ces villes qui ont
amené des foules énormes et bien
toujours ça a été dans l'ordre parce que
les lits bernard est passée par là et
dans mont pellier il y a des pancartes
des flèches indicatrices et les gens
suivant l'endroit d'où ils viennent sont
propulsés vers tel ou tel lieu les uns
doivent loger dans un jardin public les
autres dans une rue les autres sur une
place les autres sur l'esplanade et ils
vont y trouve une pancarte qui les
attend et il s'installe pour la nuit il
fait beau il fait chaud il fait doux
alors on dormira leur monseigneur de
cabrières qui est l'évêque de
montpellier a ouvert sa cathédrale et il
y a plusieurs milliers de femmes et
d'enfants qui vont passer la nuit dans
la cathédrale sous la simple
surveillance d'un beau dommage et steve
kir a eu
puis alors à toute la nuit en comme la
nuit est longue il y en a peut-être qui
est même sûrement quelques-uns qui
saucissonnent sous la statue de la
vierge mais tout ça ça fait partie de ce
grand jour vers 2 heures du matin il
fait froid dans les rues tout à coup
alors les gens qui ont froid rentrer
dans les cafés les cafés n'ont pas fermé
bien entendu il reste ouvert toute la
nuit on prend quelque chose de chaud
dans les cafés et puis le lendemain à
l'aube
c'est une nouvelle marée qui convergent
vers montpellier les trains les trains
ne se sont pas arrêtées de la nuit et
puis les charrettes et les voitures les
autos et les cyclistes et les piétons
voici des femmes des délégations de
femmes elles avancent en costume de
carcassonne de narbonne de parts
où et puis des gens de toutes classes de
toute allure les propriétaires voisine
les ouvriers les petits vignerons
pauvres tout le monde avance tout le
monde est là il y a une immense
banderole place de la concorde
hardy a redit la tâche est belle les
pitous ces groupes qui s'avance qui
s'avance qui piétinent dans les rues ont
tous des pancartes mort aux vins
artificiel nous irons jusqu où marcelin
albert nous conduire à deux bouts les
forçats de la fin on a pu y aller
des écriteaux en france et en provençal
une image génère une imagination folle
en avance on piétine ils sont là dans
toutes les rues les ruelles n'ya pas
l'endroit de montpellier qui ne soit
grouillant de foule
savez vous combien ils sont là ce matin
là dans mont pellier 800 mille huit cent
mille qui sont venus à l'appel de bars
cela albert vit cent mille qui sont
venus crier
enfin abandonnera ton le midi et 11
heures
tout à coup
un cri dans la foule dans la foule
énorme dans la foule immense
on vient de reconnaître marcelin albert
et oui il est là tout petit tout frêle
et trois au milieu de cette foule
gigantesque qui n'est venu que pour lui
on le reconnaît on l'acclament des gens
le hissent sur leurs épaules
on le porte en triomphe une femme
s'approche en pleurant lui tend son
nouveau né a touché le monsieur
marcelin-albert touché le je vous en
supplie lui mécaniquement touche
l'enfant les femmes pleurent les hommes
gravement se découvre on passe près d'un
plat talla les platanes ça lui connaît
marcelin albert il attrape les branches
il saute dans platane et ils adressent à
tous ces gens des paroles de bienvenue
alors on l'acclament de nouveau on
l'emportent de nouveau on le conduit
jusqu'à l'esplanade où se dresse
l'estrade et là il monte sur l'estrade
devant cette mère humaine devant cet
océan
imaginez le comte arc qui a dû avoir
lieu à ce moment là entre ces gens et
celui qu'on appelle plus loups si gallas
est bien fini maintenant pour tous ces
gens là il est le rédempteur il est
l'apôtre et il parle
elie il y a trois mois seulement trois
mois
oui moi marcelin-albert j'étais seul
j'étais tout seul
et là maintenant avec moi que vois-je
vous êtes 800 milles et l'acclamation et
la communion il y a rarement de tels
minutes vous êtes dit marcelin-albert la
plus grande armée du travail qui ait
jamais été réunies
et cette arme est maintenant de
désarmera plus et ferroul prend la
parole
le bon docteur ferroul ce médecin
socialiste
le meilleur médecin de l'art bonne mais
le plus pauvre parce qu'il soit une
presque tout le monde sans demander
d'argent
il suffit d'être pour alors on ne paie
pas il a été député il est socialiste
mais il est l'ami de royalistes mistral
et puis où ils croient l'au delà le
moins docteur ferroul
il fait tourner les tables il évoque les
esprits on lem le docteur ferroul et il
est là côté de marcel albert c'est vrai
maintenant qu'il est son fidèle
lieutenant elle dit demain 10 juin
demain je fermerai ma mairie demain 10
juin
j y serai sur ma mairie le drapeau noir
et demain je jetterai mon écharpe de
maire au gouvernement
acclamations et il y à là l'adjoint le
maire-adjoint de carcassonne qui lui est
venue avec son écharpe et lui il joint
le geste à la parole il enlève il
arrache son écharpe et la jette à la
foule et la foule se saisit de les chars
pour la déchire en morceaux chacun veut
un morceau pour l'emmener comme
l'emporter comme une relique
oui ce soir là à montpellier le midi a
choisi lille légalité et dès le
lendemain dès le lendemain les
démissions pleuvent sur les bureaux des
préfets et les maires démissionnent en
bloc les conseils municipaux démissionne
n'est préfet ne savent plus quoi faire
de ces démissions il ya là des centaines
et des centaines des centaines toutes
les mairies ferme
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire une
mairie qui fermait bien mal entendu si
si on veut déclarer la naissance d'un
enfant ne peut pas plus d'état civil on
veut déclarer un décès on peut pas et
même n'y a plus de permis d'inhumer
quand on enterre les morts dans les
cimetières c'est en fraude peu puis se
marier plus de mariage aura bien
quelques curés même un évêque qui est
feront les mariages simplement religieux
est ce qu ont d'ailleurs poursuivi plus
tard et paieront des amendes parce qu'on
n'a pas le droit de faire ça
alors oui le midi paralysé et la grève
des impôts bien entendu plus à sous ne
tombe dans l'escarcelle de l'état alors
à paris clemenceau se rend compte que ça
va beaucoup plus loin qu'il ne l'avait
pensé
attention les manceaux connaît bien
l'histoire
il sait que depuis très longtemps depuis
un certain simon de montfort il y a des
ferments dans le midi qu'il vaut mieux
ne pas faire vivre et il a appris que le
docteur ferroul qui depuis longtemps à
les rêves d'autonomie a hissé à côté du
drapeau noir sur sa mairie le drapeau
rouge à croix d'argent du languedoc
alors que les manceaux demande au
général picard son ministre de la guerre
d'envoyer des troupes dans le midi et
les premières troupes arrivent à l'art
bonne et on comprend vite dans les
milieux de ceux qui appellent à la
révolte
on comprend vite que des coups directs
monte doit être donnée à la révolte et
dans la nuit du 18 au 19 juin 1907 il y
a dans les rues d'argeliers u 7 à 8000
vignerons qui sont là avec des bâtons
car on sait on l'a appris que la troupe
marché sur argelier les gendarmes
marchera geôliers c'est sûrement pour
arrêter le rédempteur c'est sûrement
pour arrêter l'apôtre pour arrêter
marcelin albert et les hommes sont là
autour de marcelin albert on te laissera
pas arrêter marcellin on te fera un
rempart de nos corps marcelin albert
leur parle du non je ne veux pas de sens
depuis le début je ne dis pas de
violence
nous tenons le bon bout ils ont peur
maintenant de nous mais alors surtout
pas je ne me laisserai pas arrêté et je
ne vous quitterai pas et il disparaît
dans l'année
un peu plus tard et trop par yves
ceinture entièrement cercle entièrement
argelier 200 gendarmes s'avance dans le
village le colonel ordioni veut enfoncer
la porte du café de la fenêtre s'ouvre
c'est madame marcelin albert et non ne
l'enfoncé pas elle est ouverte la porte
on entre sur une table une lettre de
marcelin albert à clemenceau monsieur le
président du conseil
je ne suis qu'un gars entre beaucoup
d'autres gueule alors on arrête
simplement les membres du comité qui
viennent d'ailleurs se livrer et on les
écrous le soir même à la prison de
montpellier est à 4 heures du matin dans
cette même nuit un demi corps d'armée
occupe narbonne et on arrête ferroul on
le conduit dans la voiture cellulaire
qui est venu le prendre et il faut des
cuirassiers tout autour de la voiture
car la foule
réveillez veut la prendre d'assaut et
cette foule à ça et les cuirassiers de
deux coups de pierres alors deux fois ou
trois fois les crassiers charles on les
appelle on l'écrit on les u assassin
assassin assassin et le docteur ferroul
retrouve ce d'argeliers à la prison de
mont pellier et le lendemain matin il
n'y a qu'une partie bien sûr une faible
partie des habitants de narbonne qui ont
appris que ferroul avaient été arrêtés
mais le matin on le sait toute la ville
le sait il y un véritable climat
d'insurrection qui montrent à travers la
ville et au début de la première ni deux
généraux qui se promènent tranquillement
devisant tout à coup se voit entouré par
une foule hostile
on les insulte on les injurie ont fait
voler leur képi partait on les secours
les malmène on va les lyncher noms des
officiers arrive revolver au poing les
dégagent les emporte très vite les
emmène très vite vers l'hôtel de ville
et puis le soir toute une foule veut
prendre d'assaut la sous préfecture il
faut que les soldats qu'ils occupent les
hommes du 139e tirs en l'air pour se
dégager et vite par téléphone ont fait
appel au 10e régiment de cuirassiers
qu'il vienne qu'il dégage qu'ils
chassent cette foule et le régiment se
met en branle à travers les rues de
montpellier rues étroites pour la
plupart et alors là c'est pour eux un
calvaire parce que de partout de toutes
les fenêtres leur jettent des
projectiles ils avancent sous une
véritable pluie de projectiles et puis
par terre on leur lance des voitures à
bras dans leurs chevaux des des
guéridons les chevaux reçoivent tous à
des chevaux but à l'homme tombe à terre
et peu à peu à mesure qu'ils avancent et
même comme la nuit est tombée on tend
des cordes en travers les ruelles et les
chevaux se prennent dans ses cordes et
les curation peu à peu le sentiment
qu'ils sont pris comme dans une sorte de
nas ils ont peur
mais alors la comme toujours dans ces
sorte de tragédie on ne sait pas comment
ça commence pourquoi ça commence dans
cette mini un café le méridional il
était clair et peut-être est-ce être est
ce tout simplement cette tache de
lumière qui fait que un réflexe sommes
mère se dégage sur ses hommes il y en a
un qui tire dans la vitrine puis
d'autres tirs il tire tous dans la
vitrine du café et à l'intérieur un
homme un consommateur monsieur ramant
être qu'elle avec sa fille il tombe il
est mort et sa fille grièvement blessée
alors il ya les gens qui sortent des
maisons comment sécurité qui tirent
alors qu'on n'a rien fait alors les gens
de toutes parts leur lancent des pierres
et c'est un combat dans la nuit alors
que tous les réverbères ont éclaté il
fait noir on ne se voit pas et c'est
tant mieux d'ailleurs sans sa soeur
était bien payé alors les déclarations
reçoivent des pierres et retiré tirs à
balle on retrouvera 15 blessés à bâle et
même là un sous-officier voyant un gamin
de 14 ans le visent longuement comme à
l'exercice et tire
l'enfant est atteint une balle qui entre
dans le rein gauche qui ressort par la
poitrine miraculeusement il survivra
alors le lendemain matin
imaginez le climat à montpellier après
cette nuit d'affrontements
ce massacre inutile la ville subit comme
une occupation militaire mais oui les
soldats rue les cuirassiers ont eu tout
ce qu'un uniforme
puis au début de l'après midi un
policier inspecteur de police qui a
participé à l'arrestation de ferroul il
s'appelle grosso comme et l'imprudence
de se promener dans l'art bol et
quelqu'un leur connaît je le reconnais
il est de ceux qui ont arrêté ferroul
c'est un mouchard à mouchard la foule
s'est ruée sur lui
on ne sait jamais comment réagir à une
foule surtout une foule douloureuse une
foule qui pleurent des morts et des
blessés
alors on sait jette sur lui on lui
arrache ses vêtements le bas on y donne
des coups de pied des coups de poing il
est en sang on va lynché et puis il ya
des gens dans cette foule guy nom ne
tuez pas on le conduit au comité
viticole qui n'est pas loin pour qu'on
le garde
puis alors là au lieu d'y rester dit en
sécurité c'est imbécile et bien il
s'enfuit profite d'un moment
d'inattention
il s'enfuit et naturellement le rattrape
et on le pousse vers le canal on le
pousse sur le pont du canal et là hop
aux gènes d'organes
il est en sang il est affaibli par les
coups qu'il a reçus
ça doit être un homme vigoureux charisme
et à l'ag ils nagent très bien alors lui
jettent des pierres ya quelqu'un qui à
revolver qui tire qui tirent ils nagent
toujours et il s'en tire et à 100 mètres
de là y'a des gens qui lui disent allez
donnez nous la main remonter
et ce sont ces gens là qui veulent le
sauver qui dit on va le conduire à
l'hôtel de ville et il marche avec se
blesser qu'ils soutiennent vers l'hôtel
de ville et puis la foule les a rejoint
et la foule m'a vers l'hôtel de ville
j'ai des pincettes images tout à l'heure
cette foule qui cette fois s'est calmé
cette foule qui ne veut que dire sa
souffrance
et alors vous vous souvenez ces soldats
baïonnette au canon qui s'est lancé
quitté cinq morts cinq morts dont une
jeune fille on montrera l'endroit où
cette jeune fille a été tuée le crâne
éclaté 20 ans et puis on défilera devant
son lit demain les émeutes de narbonne
font tache d'huile à perpignan le même
soir la foule prend d'assaut la
préfecture et commence à la brûler il
faudra deux heures pour qu'on dégage le
préfet monsieur d'autres aimait sa
famille et qu'on les sauve à lodève la
foule les vignerons arrête le sous
préfet monsieur willy on le veut le
prendre comme otages si on n'obtient pas
satisfaction sur les demandes
essentielles qu'on présente et bien on
le tuera il faut que les autorités
préfectorales haillan la prison de
montpellier et supplient les gens du
comité d'argeliers obtenait sa
libération et les gens du comité les
collaborateurs de marcelin albert
demande et obtienne cette libération
mais tout cela ce sont des incidents
sans gravité
à côté de ce qui se passe le même soir à
agde à agde un régiment vient d'arriver
depuis peu de temps
c'est le dix septième 17ème régiment
d'infanterie il vient de béziers est
d'ailleurs la plupart de ces soldats
sont origine de la région originaire de
la région ryanair de béziers et pendant
l'après-midi et bien beaucoup de gens de
la ville dam de leurs offert à boire
dans les cafés seul vin et pour cause
n'est pas cher ils ont beaucoup bu ces
jeunes gens on leur a dit un fou nous
protégerait des uhlans de clemenceau
parce qu'on ne parle que du massacre de
narbonne et puis dans la fin de
l'après-midi le bruit a couru un bruit
pourquoi on ne sait pas on est en train
de massacrer à béziers voilà ces jeunes
gens qui pensent à leurs familles qui
sont à béziers et pourtant il rentre à
la caserne et il n'y a pas d'incident
l'appel de 9 heures ils gagnent leur
chambre et est un peu plus tard c'est la
foule les civils qui rentre dans la
caserne et qui leur cri vous n'allez pas
laisser tuer vos familles à béziers les
fenêtres s'ouvrent les soldats écoute et
se dessine
est il des saints ils ont pris leurs
fusils ils ont la crosse en l'air ça y
est c'est fait des soldats du xviie ce
meeting à la même heure dans l'autre
caserne de la ville la caserne mirabel
les autres soldats se mutinent les deux
groupes se rassemblent les civils
enfoncent la porte de la poudrière
distribuer des cartouches aux soldats
maintenant ils sont entre 500 et 600
réunis lacroix sans lait et ils vont
marcher sur béziers musique en tête ils
partent dans la nuit et derrière il y a
des charrettes
ce sont des gens qui ont pensé à ceux
qui seraient fatigués ou il y à 18
kilomètres pour arriver à béziers à
minuit on l'apprend à béziers que les
mutins dame de la 17e mutine est en
marche
immédiatement les autorités militaires
inter se veulent intercepter ces mutins
on met des groupes des forces militaires
et des gendarmes devant la ville et
quand les mutins paraissent toujours
musique en tête et bien il y à un
commandant qui s'approche d'eux qui leur
dit mais mes enfants c'est la folie
allons vous savez ce que vous risquez
rentrer tranquillement à la caserne de
béziers on vous y attend
on massacre nos familles crient les
jeunes gens nous n'allons pas laisser
faire ça et puis c'est un général qui
s'approche il veut parlementer il
s'appelle le général la croisade par oui
c'est son nom et leur parle leur langue
les soldats sont respectueux où cette
même à générale du zoo vous en faites
pas mon général vous savez on on veut de
mal à personne
on veut on veut simplement que nos
familles soir traité comme il convient
après quoi on ira à la caserne
on y va à la caserne de béziers le
général qui a conscience s'en va à
l'accasion de béziers où naturellement
les mutins n'arriveront jamais parce que
ils s'arrêteront sur les allées paul
riquet fêté par les habitants de béziers
et la installant avec des cordes
attachés à des platanes une sorte de
camp von apportera de la paille se
coucheront là pour la nuit sont fatigués
et le matin les gens de béziers
viendront les voir dormir et puis on
leur apportera dès qu'ils seront
réveillés de la nourriture de la boue
son de l'argent frais une quête pour eux
4000 francs puis toute la journée les
autorités essaieront de négocier de
parlementer rien à faire quand des
gendarmes s'approcheront immédiatement
les soldats du xviie qui roulait alors
les gendarmes s'éloigneront et puis dans
l'après midi on fera venir des gens
d'argeliers le comité d'argeliers même
ce comité n'obtiendra rien alors on va
voir arriver un général à cheval suivi
d'un officier de cavalerie et d'un porte
fanions ils fendent la foule
c'est le général bayou il est célèbre
le général bayou parce que quelques
temps avant il n'a pas craint de dire
publiquement que la france devait
récupérer l'alsace et la lorraine allons
la sanctionner général n'a pas le droit
de dire ça mais alors vous imaginez sa
popularité en france et alors quand ils
arrivent on le dit assez le général
bayou c'est le brave général bayou bravo
bon là pour le clame le mutin aussi
applaudi il aime bien le général bayou
général bayou leur part l'onu alan mes
enfants vous me connaissez je crois que
je suis un chef juste et vous chiez que
vous êtes des bons garçons vous savez
pas ce n'est pas grave
alors vous allez rentrer à la caserne je
vous conduis moi même à la caserne de
béziers puis alors demain vous
repartirez pointe et les mutins sont
tout disposés à suivre le brave général
bayou bahia toujours les fortes têtes y
en a un qui dit ah oui ma pas de
punitions pas de punitions individuel
prométhée le midi mais écoutez mes
enfants moi je peux pas vous promettre
side cars que le gouvernement québécois
à bas tant pis on n'y va pas et voient
la clef pour parler du général bayou ont
échoué lorsque quelqu'un sans la foulée
la jta carrés de papier laporta bayou
qui tout heureux crime et voilà un
message de monsieur clemenceau que le
sous préfet a pris par téléphone
il n'y aura pas de punitions
individuelle alors un grand cri de joie
c'est fait et comme aller seul homme les
mutins du xviie gagne la caserne de
béziers et partiront le lendemain très
tranquillement pour la caserne
or le message de clemenceau le prétendu
message de clemenceau était un faux
improvisée par un collaborateur du sous
préfet qui voulait que toute cette
affaire finissent le résultat sera que
quelques jours plus tard les mutins du
xviie 550 mutins du xviie seront
embarqués pour la tunisie pour le sud
tunis où ils seront traités aussi
durement aussi cruellement que les trop
célèbre banda avec tout cela comporte
mauvais traitements épidémie de
dysenterie plusieurs mains et le
souvenir de cette mutinerie de ce coup
de folie de quelques heures poursuivra
le 17e jusque pendant la guerre de 14 18
le régiment qu'on appelle un régiment
déshonoré est envoyé à l'attack d'une
position imprenable et sans préparation
d'artillerie 300 partent à l'assaut sept
reviennent
et marcelin albert où est-il le 23 juin
une voiture un fiacre s'arrête devant le
ministère de l'intérieur place beauvau à
paris
en fait marcelin albert s'est caché dans
le clocher d'argeliers c'est le bon curé
qui lui a donné l'hospitalité mais il
tient plus en place il a décidé de
partir pour paris il veut voir clémence
alors il demande il est descendu fiacre
avec sa pauvre valise en carton ses
vêtements froissés son col salles sont
beaux papillons blancs son noeud
papillon tout ou noir sas falise
attachés par des ficelles et demande à
voir monsieur clemenceau clemenceau qui
sait très bien ce qu'il fait le fait
attendre 20 minutes d'antichan qui le
fait entrer
il est là debout son chapeau dans une
main la valise dans l'autre on paie très
gêné si vous dit que le manceau y
montera fauteuil il pose sa valise par
terre il a su est d'emblée clemenceau
attaque comme il a toujours fait comme
il fera toujours
eh bien vous en avez fait de belles vous
c'est vous qui êtes responsable de tout
ce désordre c'est mort c'est vous
monsieur clément soudi marcelin albert
j'ai peut-être des torts mais vous aussi
alors dès qu'il ya une grève d'un porto
ou cours et puis alors nous dans le midi
on meurt de faim et vous ne vous montrez
même pas alors dit clémence où vous ne
vous rendez pas compte que vous avez
fait le jeu de la réaction il ya des
royalistes parmi vos meneur sépaq le duc
d'orléans est à nos portes du d'orléans
c'est le prétendant la couronne de
france l'eure marcel albert est affolée
comment est ce qu'il aurait fait ça sans
le vouloir
mais monsieur le président je suis
républicain je suis patriote je me suis
engagé en soixante dix c'est pas
possible ce que vous dites et le pauvre
homme se met à pleurer
bon alors d'un coup clemenceau google
met sa voix se fait amicale bon
le sait bien vous êtes un brave homme
alors voilà vous allez repartir
et puis vous allez réunir les maires et
vous allez leur dire qu'il faut rentrer
dans la légalité
s'il rentre dans la légalité moi je
promets de tout faire pour réprimer la
fraude est ce que vous voulez m'aider
widy marcelin albert mais vous savez je
suis pas sûr de réussir au bas ça ne
fait rien du clemenceau partait toujours
et puis vous pourrez vous constituer
prisonnier ce qui sera une bonne chose
il faut que la loi triangle force doit
être à la loi parce la halle mais bon
vous avez l'argent pour repartir du
marcelin-albert g50 franche pas si ça va
suffire
bon dit que le manceau qui glisse un
billet de 100 francs dans la manne part
cela albert toujours qu'on lit et l'ont
conduit à travers le ministère un peu
vide c'est un dimanche ne reconduit
jusqu'à la porte de la rue des saussaies
lui serre la main
mon voyage marcelin albert et marcelin
va tout de suite prendre le tram et
trois minutes à peine après qu'il aura
quitté le ministère clemenceau fait
prévenir la presse que marcellin albert
le chef de la révolte du midi est venu
pleurer dans son cabinet que lui
clemenceau grand seigneur lui
adolescents francs et avant même que le
train amène marcelin-albert dans le midi
tous les journaux du midi annonce que le
rédempteur l'apôtre a touché 100 francs
de clemenceau il s'est laissé acheter
pauvre marcelin-albert alors il ira se
constituer prisonnier à montpellier et
dans sa cellule ses compagnons
refuseront de lui adresser la parole
maintenant les plus rédempteur il n'est
plus l'apôtre il est le traître
alors un échec
la révolte des vignerons du midi non le
29 juin
enfin le parlement vote la loi qu'on
attendait depuis si longtemps la loi qui
réprime la fraude
et puis le gouvernement annonce qu'on ne
réclamera pas les impôts en retard aux
vignerons qui ne peuvent les payer
et puis le 2 où on libère tous ceux qui
sont arrêtés et la foule acclame ferroul
les cm oui et ceux qui l'entourent
pamart cela admet il rentre dans son
village il rentre à la nuit il se glisse
dans les rues ne veux pas qu'on sache
qu'il est là mais la légende argelier le
voit on l'entourent
on le bouscule à bas le traître le
[ __ ] et quelqu'un dit et si on
demandait à un platane alors il s'enfuit
devant la meute
il s'engouffre dans sa maison se
claquemurent vraiment est-il un traître
quelques jours plus tard le gouvernement
prend un décret on n'aura plus le droit
de vendre du vin sous l'appellation de
vin s'il n'est fait de jus de raisin
frais ou de raisin frais c'est tout ce
qu'on demande et c'est tout ce que
demandait marcelin-albert depuis des
années est-ce que simon marty seul à
albert dans son café d'argeliers n'avait
pas un jour levé l'étendard de la
révolte on aurait obtenu tout ça
on parlera longtemps dans le midi de la
révolte des vignerons et même ailleurs à
paris un chansonnier montéhus obtiendra
la loi en chantant l'hymne aux soldats
du xviie longtemps le dernier souvenir
de la révolte des vignerons sera le
clairon qu antoine marty à garder
soigneusement vous souvenez le clairon
avec lequel il avait sonné l'appel dans
les rues d'argeliers le dimanche 11 mars
le clairon avec lequel il avait marché
devant les hommes d'argeliers le clairon
qui avait sonné le chant du départ des
vignerons alors oui il avait son clairon
et même 30 ans et même 40 ans après il
avait toujours ce clairon il
vieillissait et on venait de loin pour
le voir se plairont et puis en 1947 de
bonnes âmes en donner une idée à marty
pourquoi tu n'en verrai pas ton clairon
a ce talent est installé oui tu devrait
envoyer ton clairon à staline mon
clairon oui ton clairon alors ils te
remercierai sûrement ils inviteraient
gratuitement et séjourner enrichi alors
antoine marty y envoyer son clairon
installé et staline n'a jamais répondu
c'est ainsi que marty antoine marty a
perdu un clairon historique et qu'il n'a
jamais vu la russie soviétique
[Musique]